OK, we do have some important breaking news
today about the hopefully forthcoming corona
virus vaccine.
As many of you know, Donald Trump has put
many political eggs in the basket of being
able to announce a corona virus vaccine before
Election Day.
And Donald Trump has for a while now been
talking about could be mid-October, could
be even sooner.
And remember that this was never going to
be a standard FDA approval for the vaccine.
The hope was what Trump was counting on was
an emergency use authorization from the FDA.
Now, at its core, from the starting point,
an E Yueh is already not as rigorous of a
process as a full approval for a vaccine.
But even the possibility of the emergency
use authorization now is significantly less
likely because the FDA announced just hours
ago that it's going to be tightening up the
authorization standards for vaccine emergency
use, making it very unlikely that Donald Trump
is going to get this announcement before Election
Day.
Now, this matters for two reasons.
First of all, this matters from a public health
standpoint.
We need a vaccine and it's going to be longer
than some hoped for the U.A..
Now, the counter point is we all knew that
Trump wanted to announce the U.A. even though
the vaccine doses were never really going
to be available widely in 2020.
So this may not really change when the average
person will get the vaccine.
It's merely going to change Donald Trump getting
to announce it before the election.
And that's why there's a big political implication
here.
Donald Trump was counting on being booted
in the polls by being able to say we got a
vaccine.
Now, we knew all along.
That even if he got the emergency use authorization
in the next few weeks before the election,
it was going to be a while before anybody
could really get the vaccine.
Any significant number?
A number of people.
But incredibly, this may be even more self-inflicted
damage by Donald Trump, because part of the
reason why the FDA is now saying we're going
to make it tougher, stricter.
We're going to boost transparency.
Part of the reason they are doing this is
because so many people have expressed concern
that Donald Trump has politicized the vaccine
and people are rightly skeptical about what
it would really mean for an early UAI from
the FDA.
If the FDA is merely under the thumb of Donald
Trump, the FDA is going to put in place a
number of new requirements.
It is going to put in place the requirement
of following participants in these late stage
chronic clinical trials for a median of at
least two months, starting after the second
dose of the vaccine.
The predominant number of vaccines being tested
are two doses, typically separated by about
30 days per the News Times as a sign that
the vaccine works.
The agency also is planning to look more closely
at people with severe cases of corona virus
and looking at specifically people in the
placebo groups who got Corona virus and doing
a lot more than what some were hoping would
be done if you were hoping for an early approval.
This is going to take time.
And the agency previously said that any vaccine
would have to be at least 50 percent more
effective than a placebo.
So now we're hearing from all sorts of experts,
including Paul Offit, who directs the Vaccine
Education Center at Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia.
He says, quote, It's hard to imagine how an
emergency use authorization could possibly
occur before December.
Madonna has now said they are unlikely to
have the required data by the end of October.
AstraZeneca has had to stop their trial as
they're looking into this serious neurological
problem that happened to a participant in
that trial.
Pfizer had a vaccine which conceivably could
have been the one that maybe in October could
have gotten an emergency use authorization.
But based on the new restrictions, that is
likely to be postponed.
Now, there is another sort of parallel story
to this, which is that a whole bunch of the
country still says they're not going to get
a coronavirus vaccine.
They will not seek it out.
And that is more Trump people than Biden people.
People who, thanks in part to Donald Trump's
administration, still aren't taking coronavirus
seriously.
There is new data from the Pew Research Center
which reports that the percentage of Americans
who say they would get the vaccine if it were
available today has dropped to just about
50 percent.
Back in May, in that same study, 72 percent
of respondents said I'd get the vaccine.
Now, just over 50 percent of respondents say
they would get the vaccine.
So consider the insanity of this country on
the one hand.
Trump has been banking on announcing a vaccine
that he had no role in developing to try to
get himself reelected.
On the other hand, it's his followers who
disproportionately don't plan to get the vaccine
anyway.
Raising the question of, well, would the vaccine
announcement even really help Trump that much?
I don't know the answer.
It's stunning stuff, and it doesn't seem as
though Donald Trump is going to get that announcement.
Now, one other issue to talk about.
This is a broader issue and we're looking
into bringing an expert on to ask them about
it.
Should vaccines ever be authorized via an
emergency use authorization?
Anyway, there are critics who say new ways
are not for vaccines.
OK, you do you get early data that room desk
Sivir is working.
You do an emergency use authorization with
with no caveats and restrictions.
You get early data that dexamethasone is reducing
mortality and serious coronavirus patient.
You do an emergency use authorization for
a vaccine.
You don't do it, say some critics.
Now, there are others who say you do want
to keep an U.A. for a vaccine on the table
when you have thousands of people a week dying.
If you get an efficacy signal, that is good
enough and what good enough means, of course,
needs to be delineated.
More specifically, you consider and UAI, then
you need to figure out do any of the vaccines
that we actually have available warrant and
UAI.
And that's a more specific question to be
answered.
Reasonable people can disagree about that
from a political.
Point, it does not appear that Donald Trump
is going to get it.
We're going to have more on vaccination on
The David Pakman Show Instagram.
That's David Pakman show on Instagram.
Make sure you're following us.